we know that in-person work really
favored the extrovert we know that right
and we know that a lot of introverts
suffered at work and then when we all
was sent home the introverts were like
this is the best right and all the
extroverts really suffered and so when
we're saying hey everybody come to back
to work all the inters are going nope no
no I I work better at home right and the
answer is great except for the fact that
there's other people here as well and
you have to do it as an active service
which is yes I do work better at home
but I'm going to come to the office now
and then because I know that it's the
right thing to do for those who work
differently from me than me and the
extroverts have to say I know that I
want everybody to come back to work
because I like it but I recognize that
some people need space to get their work
done separately and so I'm going to
allow for flexibility at work and so I
think as an act of service to each other
we all have to let go a little bit of
what we want there's the combined
problem of young people who started
their careers or early in their careers
tasted work from home and they think
it's the world's greatest thing except
for the fact that they're some they're
suffering serious mental fitness
challenges I don't use the term mental
health I don't like the term mental
health because mental health sounds like
a standard that you have to reach and
most of us are feeling like you either
have it or you don't I believe in mental
Fitness which is something you have to
constantly work on and they're suffering
serious mental Fitness Challen Alles
right and the anxiety is is getting
worse they come to work they freak out
and they say you see I can't ever come
to work not failing to recognize that
it's the being at home that's creating
the anxiety and so I do think that we
have to find mechanisms to bring people
back to work or spend time with each
other do plenty of offsites whatever it
is because I think 100% distributed work
um is bad for people but I do think of
it as an act of as an act of service I
think that we have to let go a little
bit of what we want for the good of
others and for the good of the team in